I'm here with with Donald Robertson
somebody who's been absolutely central
in the modern stoic movement I got a
nice chance to sit down with you and
after stoic on stoic on X all the travel
involved Donald organized it this year
and actually one of the first questions
I want to ask you about almost seems a
little life hack II sort of thing you
know I you know a lot about the sort of
schedule that you keep in part because
of our involvement and I'm amazed I'm a
busy guy myself who gets a lot done but
I see you getting way more done than I
do and every time that I see you you
don't look Haggard or totally worn out
how do you do it
and I'm not look what I'm checking out
what does it say different questions
better having a lot done is has two
answers to one and I really the stuff
that I'm doing I feel like had to spend
most my time doing my whole beat so I
just really love the stuff that I'm
doing it doesn't seem like a tool to me
so I'm chaotic thinking of mysticism you
know what I mean usually in the morning
yeah yeah you know walking down the
street so there's more a thing thought
and energy goes into something that for
one of them was a passion and you loved
it would be if you were just doing a
chore so I'm lucky to be able to do my
hobby for a living and so I naturally
investments anything Jenna but also I
often will have from the cognitive
therapy we have activity schedules so
the morning our friend Heriberto format
created and has a separate box for each
hour of the day and our plot plot
roughly what I'm going to use the first
ever is usually answering the meals
planning things yeah and then what am I
gonna do in the rest of the hours that
try and keep track of how am i spending
my time throughout the day and do the
things that planning and generally what
I find is that I it's impossible to do
what they on track
yeah it's possible stay on track and I
usually overestimate how much
I'm going to get done so I want to be
another lover more forgiving on myself
by doing that because I realized yet
maybe I was sent on real estate
yeah Halsey TV for a wife so I could do
answering my emails maybe actually takes
longer than I always takes longer yeah
so that and then then in terms of like
not being too frazzled
why you know the funny thing is because
I walk people their interest to us or
some talk about taking Port Charles
yeah and I called showers and coffee I
are what get me like Michael tomorrow
humming yeah I mean there's no way it's
completely able to get through class
movies if I hadn't had a freezing cold
shower and I got a we were both were
sleep-deprived yeah when I was working
away I feel like almost like it checked
my brain and many thinking that it
wasn't as tired as actually was it
supposed to it once it becomes winter
going outside for a couple minutes could
work as well yeah yeah it was cool I was
gonna say my major was Madsen I would
work down south but so are you
you got into stoicism a long time ago
but you were you were doing it primarily
but if I remember right through
cognitive behavior therapy first or am I
wrong about that pretty much uh more or
less lis pendens
I I got interested I was I can remember
I really look was the struggles we have
i well but but I the first quarter story
is the like everybody else chance to see
and there's a neuticle admission i and
my philosophy degree so oh your next
dose is yeah yeah right and so I
finished University I spent four years
you did four years in Scotland studying
philosophy and you know these things are
okay at me really satisfyingly somehow
in the closest friend was existentialism
see I offer a kind of philosophy of life
but it was also overly complicated and
obscure why
not really much of a gait creator and
value there you know I didn't want to
offer free concrete very sometimes so I
in the popularity existentialism ISM I
you know I can't find a [ __ ] lasted a
few decades and then it kind of fizzled
out as well yeah
so it wasn't the dancing like next
option and I didn't really have I'm
sorry you know I wanted something from
philosophy I wasn't really exciting
doing it and I was fainting a Tibetan
Buddhism but I also felt the lead to it
was a gap for something that was more
consistent with my chest psychotherapy
and self-help and okay no more familiar
to the West on false off production than
Buddhism yeah business in Tibet exotic
to me I guess I was reading some
oriental texts like the don't DJ DJ the
Book of Changes is a good way you know
review the article this is connect cool
I've also been no idea what it means
yeah or I don't apply it yeah I really
heard DJ mean extent ruling his stage is
like frying small fish
I thought maybe yes actually means maybe
someone could explain it to me but I was
kidding I'm scratching my head a lot of
time'n thinking there's some good advice
in has a lot of really obscure stuff
that it just puzzles me so I think I
stumbled across this isn't by accident
because I chose meaning a bit
neoplatonism and me because I've been
interested in how you go I study told
you yeah Roger and I kind of got into
neoplatonism at birth and I was reading
how to was booked on attainers and from
that somehow I may be just as badly to
eat was ancient philosophy and
philosophies of way of life and and
reading was I realized of the different
schools of philosophy PR dole talks
about cynicism skepticism Platonism
stoicism it really still doesn't that
jump though and seems like the mean one
day he should have been focusing like
there than me one had a therapeutic
dimension the main one that had
spiritual exercises and when how does
here's a spiritual exercise can a battle
in a way that he framed in theological
terms because I thought clearly these
are what we would call psychological
exercise oh yeah and it seemed really
easy to me to say he's paying governor's
unless those oh yeah to draw up the
saved a list of cognitive behavioral
therapy techniques that correlate with
them and that's all why is nobody done
that and like a you know many books get
started because somebody thinks I missed
someone already read their book yeah it
seems like an obvious thing to do it
seemed easy as well all I'm really doing
in a way kind of commenting on work that
was already done although it turned into
a project and now it's a story Donna
yeah you know in our conversations it's
become clear to me that you in effect
besides all the other things that you
are you're you're in effect a historian
of ideas when it comes to psychotherapy
particularly to the cognitive revolution
and anything that's remotely like
stoicism so one of the questions I
wanted to ask you so we've you know we
have our EBT and CBT people that get
involved in the modern style thing and
some of them speak at that that's don't
count do you think that there's an
awareness and a larger CBT community
about these parallels between stoicism
and any sort of cognitive approach yeah
it's a funny one i I can't float away
I should somehow be responsible for and
because of your book right yeah
introducing more people so that the
there's a cave but we're gonna spend no
not as much as there should be and the
occasional you need CBD practitioners
that are into stoicism but they don't
seem any more prevalent amongst its
practitioners though there are yeah and
there's a bunch of the rebt
practitioners I think that maybe
stumbled across my book or other things
and and made the connection stronger in
them
but de la porte back here the cbt
private section of this book do you
think that's because I mean you see this
in a lot of professions you know you see
sociologists or some unaware of the
history of their discipline right or you
see there's a lot of business theory do
you think that's the case for CBT
practitioners it's not that there's just
interested in the history but they're
not getting exposed to it perhaps yeah
they see I mean you said that what is
customary deals mean the funny thing is
that is Cain apparel always thought
about what I was doing it was more than
ice cream ideals than philosophy or
psychotherapy the this stuff that was my
main interest and yeah
the philosopher CBT that it's been
really history of ideas and CBT
practitioners are the focus no training
generally is on being evidence-based and
basing what they do and model for Sarah
yeah so there's kind of implicit value
judgment the older stuff is obsolete
yeah I've known evidence-based and
therefore you have to be a lot but weary
of getting involved or looking into too
much detail it's you know that all the
really Bowser's was the evidence for us
CBT practice was initially trained their
clients to ask the question where's the
evidence for I would live this yeah and
the practitioners also kind of have that
mentality when it comes to looking at
therapy techniques particularly in
Breton I think we're as part of the NHS
those and increasing expectation of
service will justify what they're doing
yeah and that maybe is one of the things
that discourages them a lot better but I
you're right the in my experience CBT
practitioners and protective are often
know very little a bit the history not
only of psychotherapy be often they know
very well but there are as you can see
there are traditional yeah I mean I want
them know very well about ILS for
instance already if they're even and
Louisville and other forms of
psychotherapy or if they do is just like
a lot of smart training knowledge that
they've been exposed to
and in general psychotherapists and the
notable exception is opera Ellis hidden
you are more okay right that's Jeff
easily be filling into the history of
ideas
he was an arrant in a way about it and a
good way about like that sto
psychotherapy
that's unusual most all thoughts in
psychotherapy field see see see above it
yeah you know so you I mean you
mentioned CBT really matters in a way I
mean not just because it can help people
but because in Britain it's become
important medical establishment I think
it here in the United States it's one of
the most popular forms of of therapy as
well because it has demonstrated
effectiveness I don't know what the
cases in Canada or another place yeah
feel like in Canada is no it is popular
but not quite in the same way there's
also the issue of whether insurance
companies right will pay for a treatment
and I generally I think maybe the
situation is a bit different different
countries but the insurer and like see
we're not paying less therapy unless
it's a this based yeah I think that's
part of what such a place in United
States and then if you go turn NHS
practitioner affair
so maybe the space to baby doesn't
ordinary CBT yeah I had an 80% said you
myself eight five seven save it means
easy you know one of the things that you
said in a conversation that we had a
while back and you said it in other
places too is that the stoic texts have
an advantage over classic works of CBT
like the deep burn is feeling good I
know which people do hand out or go to
go to a group and they'll give you a
copy and people have it they put it on
their shelf but they don't take it down
and read it whereas you know Senecas
letters with Epictetus
discourses are the meditations people
will read those in entire life
yeah that you saw that as an advantage
to the stoic literature yeah glasses
like rhetoric Maxwell's language Manzo's
because and the you know the storage
realize this and I don't mean to do you
maybe a sense of love it disparaging of
modern simple Porthos but they're not
you know comparing them to say in a
Catholic Villa compared to Shakespeare
laughing like no Seneca is one of the
famous Pharaoh's went equity yeah that's
why he is for us so five yeah monks that
worked reserve that for a large as hogs
right um to be fair and not sometimes to
say it's like self-help my Shakespeare
or something and not respect you know
some literary giant that has like can I
say let your truck yeah one of the
self-help authors and make some good
birds they have some memorable scenes
but the the story grating you know
people have taken to our and read and
reread and reread for many centuries
yeah yeah maybe in some cases you know
history or going back to the that same
day by Bremen and that that's important
I should say because I think this the
wigs really realize that this strangely
not something that's highlighted in
cognitive therapy although it seems that
common sense if you have a teaching or a
saying and has to be memorable and it
should be a motive if it's gonna have an
impact
yeah right so I'm but there's a
therapist by season I think in therapy
sessions I come over some pretty
profound and insightful things great and
then my clients come back next week and
they don't remember me saying you know
yeah well do you know what what what you
know myself as a teacher and then
working with with clients and in other
respects to in coaching is usually when
I use a metaphor uh-huh that they come
back yeah I remember this because and
one of the things so you know you see
Cicero complaining about the Stoics that
they don't use enough rhetoric right
it's to unfairness teasing yeah under
the start paradoxes but by the time that
we get to the guys that we're talking
about seneca marcus around this and
epictetus there's metaphors all over the
place yeah they use a lot of extra cost
and I mean some of those maybe have a
special relationship historic tradition
where can talk yesterday about the
references to dying right things there's
this COBOL reference
to color and dying and stoicism yeah and
like dying and the and ships and like
some of these oh yeah I picked either
says get on the ship I'm gonna pick the
sailors yeah pick the time but now your
your mark actually funny you should say
that
you know just as an aside tada I really
feel this account gap in the market for
one of the bear we've been yet for a
book about metaphors and stoicism
because if you could easily sell a book
with us yeah and I believe I remember
one can have classical texts and we're
can try to reconstruct to some extent
yeah I think one of things that helps us
a lot is approaching a subject about a
different perspective yeah you know and
I think that recently in the course I
wrote away about Marcus Aurelius because
I I thought wonderful trying to stoicism
they don't like focusing on the
personality yeah and the biography of an
individual rather than just like more
doing like academic philosophy you know
sometimes we look at an example of a
role model and taking into account what
he said but also what he did and then
they're all shot at think shots it takes
on a very different flavor because when
we read the story birds people ask
questions they aren't the unemotional
ugly pattern right but then when you
look at war modeling Marcus less
questionable makes sense that by hisses
and his letters the front elusively
the you know it suddenly it paints a
three to three
it puts a human face on stoicism yeah it
makes it more rounded in humanized and I
think when we look at if we were to look
at the metaphors or use mysticism
I think that would allow us to look at
it from a very different perspective and
we constructed in a different way that
may address some of mr. sections oh yeah
restore a certain balance but some of
those are are cliches and Greek
philosophy and logic Charlie just
idealist always a share yeah sailing in
troubled waters and all that is just a
common metaphor account place yeah and
the
philosophers adult after session an
adult or philosophy is athletic trainer
or military and the military life these
are kind of cliches but some of them
aren't particularly resonant with Stoics
the one that I like in particularly with
that Matthias is you know going to the
philosophers it's like during the
doctor's office expect it to hurt oh
that's me and if you think about it for
a lot of our younger audience when they
go to the doctor's office they don't
generally have that experience I mean
with our age right we have bad tasting
medicine spell now all the medicines
taste wonderful
and they give you a shot for everything
and um at first you know we had to do a
bit of explaining or the metaphor even
to work right yeah maybe replaces
something yeah because it's for a reason
why there it makes me be part of that
metaphor is like me cheese if you have a
Y you can do anyhow yeah and part of
what they mean is like if you've got a
reason for doing something that you
don't make a big fuss out of having
change your pain
yeah necessarily so if you're getting a
tattoo it's things but Hospital
screaming and things you know like so
the pain doesn't seem intrinsically bad
it's two years yes you know it says
cheffy all relative to the goal we want
to achieve and so they would seem awful
to take wisdom in for children I mean
exercise that still works for that
because we exactly that would be the
exercise is also a good mix for but yeah
ancient world say a lot more people get
laid all right yeah we cheese and you
know dentistry kind of been much fun I
never really canal done very recently
just on Wednesday you know I actually
used some stoic techniques to get
through it because there were there a
few places where I have you ever done
head wound up no I'm also you know they
do known you up right
it's not it's not pain but the drill is
going in it you can feel shaking your
your job and you get a kind of queasy
feeling that's proto for a passion all
right and so you have to remind yourself
stuff to keep breathing and all of that
and I was just thinking a point this is
30 years ago
yeah this would have been just horrible
you know well you know you can get
through root canals fairly a minor that
compared to some of the pain people the
dirt if they have a reason to and what
I'm you know what's the reason I don't
want to lose the tooth yeah yeah there
are a lot of different references to
that that idea of instance isn't with
thee and so these metaphors I a few also
like it's interesting what you say about
yeah you're right the story great trick
traditionally don't played metaphors
yeah but they don't use them even they
are late weeks to excuse metaphors I
wonder if that's a shift though I mean
it's Miss Rose making a definite
criticism and I'd say hey here's here's
how I'm gonna do it he's saying look the
Aristotelians they're great with this
you know because Aristotle had his art
of rhetoric and that was one of the
things with the Peripatetic soir let's
do it as Stoics and so that's where we
get the stoic paradoxes and the dialogue
form I think he just said yeah I guess
he didn't think they don't not but they
do maybe least maybe they do maybe they
won't we basically remember the base but
then they just said a sprinkling of
expose and then on 18 April say no well
they were yeah cuz there's a dog in
there yeah a bunch of things that go
right back to Chris re person yeah
that's probably some expose a we derive
sums you know it's you know they the
wise man is like a bull protecting the
out I believe that Isis well I need a
lot of all logic ethics physics you know
yeah they give us a bunch of math laws
are better being a walled garden and
stuff like that yeah yeah maybe they'd
be shocked if they realize those are the
only best that we remain both know
anyone remembers it Travis and I were
talking today about you know who this
there's notion they got the basic animal
instincts that we this
national thing on top of it then
transforms those and so you know you've
got self-preservation but you also get
this sexual desire and our coupling
instinct and how does that get transform
and we're like well you know there
really isn't much in the stocks that we
have but you know wrote a book you know
you know why we don't know it's called I
think it it's either memory stuff it's
on the art of love and I'm sure it's not
like Ovid's art of love which is a
pickup manual yeah you wrote a book out
mary if I remember I know about remedies
for love as well yeah I said hey to her
to find the lumber and they're not to
deal with yeah you know there's all
these provinces that because we don't
have the classic literature know what I
think I said I can't pinch myself every
time I I see how the Stoics didn't talk
about that nothing I said we don't know
the nice thing to say no the things that
they haven't talked about so you know we
should always Cantonese a tea before I
try butene way anything till we got to
them so you know CLE they definitely
didn't see that's what we don't know
about them
yeah but we do have a consistent picture
of some of their core doctrines yeah and
that emerges from the timing we have a
reasonably many letter each other
survives it's just a small fraction of
what originally was the circulation yeah
I sort of synopses I mean if you sort of
almost triangulate using dodging easily
rotates Cicero and arias didymus you see
all these consistent doctrines coming up
yeah there's a reconstruction and you
can see triangle 18 things between the
different texts yeah but yeah I mean
nonetheless a lot of people who equally
maintain percent of the people today
their ancestors as a babies picked up
Marcus Aurelius and Raider and I think
now increasingly actually an interesting
question about the Morden following that
sort of sources with developing I think
it's known to you
because probably up until 10 20 years
ago most of the people who had a passing
acquaintance with sources it would've
been through maybe we do they teach the
Marcus Aurelius a night of an increasing
number you don't like that you don't
think that practices handbook as well ah
maybe I think Martha meditations
nobody's invited they but not is
definitely this more people buying all
day are bullying marketing and and maybe
haven't got ready to meeting Marcus yeah
yeah a bit teachers so it's kind of
almost a new generation of people who
are interested in stoicism that are are
getting it from commentaries yeah it
seems to me I think that's quite correct
I see that too with you know my videos
I'll get people who ask questions and
I'll be like well you should read the
have you read the text let's oh no I
didn't read I just watch the videos you
should actually read oh yeah attacks
themselves the videos are only for
explaining who likes the same thing
that's the way like taneous a good
nobody do we say that to me you know i
10 years ago into someone emailed me on
sports with its doors so tomorrow yes I
do pretty much assume they made them
yeah absolutely saying it right that's
that's why the winter and know people
say to me I've got some questions to us
awesome right yeah you know but more of
them just happen oh yeah right it says
what can we do to get people is to steer
them into reading you know the big three
let alone getting and getting on that's
reading in your sister over or do you
think that's the thing that's important
I think it's important I think publicans
is capitalism there's a bunch of things
like I mean our public engagement stuff
like the consensus it's people you know
every time you runs to it quicker if I
remember rightly it sound like one point
I think still it has a passage of
beginning of the story manual that says
by the way we strongly encourage you to
go to be partisan who is yeah it's full
of quotes from Epictetus Marcus Aurelius
and Seneca
so we're really in there as independence
it says he's of your the additions now I
recommend so we're really strongly
by steering them and helping them to go
that direction and the other thing that
happens is just quoting those texts
ourselves I've been running a course at
the moment on Marcus Aurelius just
recently finished reports of Marcus
Aurelius so kind of producing
commentaries yeah those texts that maybe
make them more accessible to people but
then you know that maybe doesn't reach a
large percentage the course I ran I
think it a talking for what Marx is like
in character yeah and they end of it
they said they no felt much more
interested in the latest iPhone engaged
whether looking more people and really
you know companion courses then I'm
Seneca and yeah anyway he remains me
when I was a student studying for loss
here's a lot of a diagram yeah but the
way I studied philosophy you know it's
not a time when people you know the
truth you say look at X stands in its
own right yeah you don't need to know
anything about the life of the author
that's what I understand hey-ya analytic
people we're all saying arguments alone
don't bother with that stuff - yeah and
I personally I just felt psychologically
as a student I find it much easier to
study bekenstein for example if I read
biographies yeah all Femina I failed
them when I was reading the track taxes
that I I cannot visualize the guy who'd
retina and having a backbone of his
personality yeah I made it more engaging
for me it brought it to life and helped
me understand some of the nuances a
little bit and so personally I feel like
it helps me a lot to study a subject if
I know more about and so sometimes I
find that with the Marcus course I was
reading people would say well though
this is a waste of time I don't need to
do anything about the guy and all that
to study this philosophy with the people
looked at that course said to me they
got they know feel they were engaging
with the text at most he probably of all
partly because just psychologically they
felt it was a dead dude because they
know the guy but also some of the
passages know took on a new meaning yeah
they could see them within the context
of his life you know I like metaphor
and one of the things that I thought a
lot about philosophy and some other
fields it's similar to berry picking you
know you go out of the woods and you you
know get your hands in there and move
the leaves around a bit before you see
where all the clusters and I pull them
out you're walking along with your thing
and you know you need a bit of
woodsmanship to get through there you
also need to persevere and like not just
looking for the ones that are
immediately there if you want to like
harvest and there's you know it's not
it's you can lay this down on a set of
principles but you really have to bring
somebody along like when you're teaching
your kid have it do it you show them
this is this kind of humble activity but
I think that working with Texas like
that unless you spend time with it
unless you apply other skills it's not
something to be sort of turned into a
routine or turned into something that's
nice yeah and we especially wants to
stop looking at the early blog
reconstruction like the quiet true yeah
and it's a cryptic tweet yeah in places
you know in some inconsistencies and we
also have sort of a history at this time
mostly you know crazy German scholars
having some wild speculations about this
and that being said yeah
sometimes which is which is determined
for you know one way or another what
sort of the conception is of this and
this one here this I mean this is like
such a great example there was a you
know sort of a pattern in German history
of philosophy which was kind of running
the show the statics don't really matter
or the Epicureans it's it's Aristotle
and Plato that are doing the real
thinking and then because the decline of
the Greek city-state you know there
isn't that organic Hegel's a great
example of them of that sort of thing
and you know you read that and then you
read the stuff texts or even at the
carrion texts and you're like how did
they come to that conclusion while they
had you know it's not some ideas already
and that's that's where you know the
reading that led to what we talked about
this before but you know I it's one of
those cases where I feel you know I'm
slightly hesitant to sound overly
dramatic you know maybe if I said I
saved for a woman the you know the tell
Artic stay in the story to created
modern endless be so there are peopIe
over two thousand years or so it's a
huge deal yeah it's amazing that way the
fact that people while modulating the
world the therapeutic applications not
just you know some stuff is ever
philosophy but they they they actual
therapeutic implications of what they
say in the world not not serious
relevant and in psychotherapy until
nineteen sixties gradually CBT didn't
really establish yourself in the
mainstream until the nineteen eighties
yeah I'm fine so it's a fairly recent
phenomena and and I promise you if you'd
gone back I can't
what psychotherapists horrifying that
this is sort of advising thought it was
kinda productive very harmful and yeah
suggests you know should directly
changing well I mean even what today
there are there are people who are
saying oh you don't want to experience
negative emotions don't don't think I've
got that sort of thing it's more good
yeah yeah positive psychology movements
there are people there are there are
some people who say that - I mean
there's a very large body of evidence
and modern psychotherapy that suggests
that accepting negative thoughts and
feelings with it came stunning in
deference if you like heart attack is
absolutely integral to mental health and
the desire to suppress or avoid
distressing thoughts and feelings and
itself is
a classical maintaining factor
depression or anxiety yeah okay so baby
you know another way that that people
moving away from sort of psychotherapy
although there have been some psycho
psychotherapeutic theorists who would
suggest that sort of things like well
you've got the people and now you've got
society so you know instead of adjusting
people to society let's let's fix let's
change society so that people don't
encounter you know as many hardships and
disappointments and then everyone will
be happy
and stoicism I think would say well
that's that's that's a pipe dream to
begin with but you know and it's the
extent which we've done it hasn't were
happier you know some of the people you
know some people the most comfortable
place of the other happiest people that
you meet yeah they you know the funny
thing is modern treatment for depression
both you know particularly I'm thinking
a behavioral activation which can grow
they are the cognitive behavioral
therapy for depression Ellis Ellis Evans
based cognitive therapy for depression
involved challenging beliefs or
challenging automatic thoughts but also
learning to act in a way changer
behavior so your daily routine was more
fulfilling and research shows this is
very much a research government change
in sign therapy not father's thing
research is pulling out quality
dismantling studies honor found that the
that part of London seems to be as
affect it was the whole treatment
package and it was one of the simplest
parts easiest to deliver yeah so the the
which and funnily enough it's a behavior
therapy really rather so then they pull
down all the behavioral activation and
combined it with some thought we've
ideas about
chunsik and extrinsic values and make
which is something that we've been doing
on this qualification Creston set
another workshop corner and valleys
clarification and Families my thing is
that sometimes more is integral to be
the way to act additionally I'm changing
your daily routines so that you're
acting more consistently in the court
with your core values yeah and becoming
clear but with those core values are
know that interestingly you know we see
this philosophy and in the psyche yeah
but at that point in particular the
boundary becomes kind of blurred because
the other therapy consists and Socratic
lis question and reflecting on your
values yeah and then a time I attempted
to avoid this more meaningful and I
would say the key part of that to that
big penis talks about something that
gets translated in English as
contradictions throughout the discourses
yeah but it's really a market which
means conflict no no and so you know we
have when you're talking about
consistency yeah we're kind of a mess
right Wow
you know this from political experience
first of all experience and and a lot of
what we're doing talking about
consistency it's being able to
articulate where there actually is a
conflict and then figuring out how were
you today or because we can't have both
we're trying to know we've been trying
to have but at the same time
and so it I think that's being talked
about but in a different language yeah
yeah you know I mean in order to work
out consistent meaningful world view you
have to do something that resembles a
sort of called reflection yeah and
funnily enough you have to do it broadly
the Socratic maddening you know you've
got you've got carefully ask yourself
questions about contradictions yeah I
expose contradictions with regards to
what do you think the most important
things in life and in fact you know
various qualification process oh there's
a Socratic questioning process you know
it's unlike philosophy event doesn't
engage with metaphysics epistemology yes
but it was batty
you know I think the other thing a lot
of cases you can't do with them yeah I
mean it focuses on this plate the
Socratic dialogues you know boys justice
yeah was courage was piety these kind of
questions but widows are just loved to
bring in some matches yeah yeah but I
wanted only you have to wait to what
extent the original Socrates actually
dead and I'm totally satisfied
yeah is anything fun so much like that
then it's interesting because there's
there's a parallel you know everybody
nature world wanted to be somebody else
so Alexander II wanna be Achilles Caesar
wanted to be Alexander areas are airing
that he wanted to be as out of time
yeah and he really was it's not a fun
gave us a picture of Socrates and was a
military guy and a historian that's
exactly what what what area
yeah I didn't see no I mean I'd love to
know what your thoughts on curtsies was
all about it because yeah he is yeah I'm
not that far removed he probably read aa
icarian so Socrates he'd studied with
the McGarry in Seattle who were the same
dude from you Clint yeah
who's were the one of Socrates so cool
so they must have had teachings are
private Socrates yeah the zero my under
probably can't the processed and passed
on to the the story the students are
candles and it is slightly distant way
they are the part of the the lineage oh
I think they definitely are I mean
they're almost like bringing together
three different Socratic a schools you
know yeah that's funny cuz you know the
weird one for that and I don't want us
to run out of time I'm a camera but
that's what we should wrap ups and after
this but is there a step aside how the
hell does you get you know pleasure is
the only good I would have out of this
Socrates guy yeah and there's some
explanations for that I never found
convincing but he found the school as
well you know and the parents still had
adherents and it's Cicero's time well
because the other hand in this bill who
is very desperate and the curious was
notable for dissociating himself from
the socratic that exactly
ye cannae fellow business
yeah so why did the 78 and no feel you
know why was a big week and they began
as if it was plausible thing to divide
Hellenism from Socrates that my
typically such a distance and they are
so so much good maybe he just wanted you
just want to present himself as as many
you know forces have done through
through history is having a pedigree an
original thinker yeah what's the Vikings
tank they said that he wouldn't be not
the curious on that and they have
Akira's well presumably I'm tentatively
he'd read other football suppose yeah
like you know but supposedly he wants it
to say that yeah really divide anything
from them yeah well the research you
know I think there was more hostility to
the epicurean school and they sort of
repaid that coming really on you get
that Sunday about us you guys you know
we've got the plaintiffs through its
affiliated the Stoics and you know
academic skepticism for a while taking
them over then you've got the Epicureans
over here and they have to Koreans are
saying nasty things about these guys and
they're saying nasty things but I pick
here it says followers and so crazy it
down like Cicero's time Sosa right
something good to say about everybody
except those Epicureans yeah yeah it
gets but itza and the negatives very
scathing yeah absolutely
I really see was Seneca campuses all
over people because people read the
first few letters to the Soviets they
think he's kind of conciliatory towards
every Koreans
yeah he actually go through those like
those first of all you notice the what
he's saying is really for a quitter cool
when he he tends to say generally he
says that he thinks if the curious was a
wise purchase minor you know sure yeah i
although you know some of these ideas
are very simple he's got some good
schools yeah as long as modifying them
way and and behind bad you know he's
insane meeting he's actually disagree if
I'm not quite fundamental level yeah and
also he thinks many of his followers are
pretty dubious and then has a corrupting
and food yeah so it is a
breaking a mealy-mouthed sort of
brilliant why
and then and summers other reasons he's
absolutely skinny they move their
bikinis yeah and then so he was liking
epictetus Panisse liking them haha yeah
and you know it stays dollars you know
there's some common ground they are
between them in terms of their this
hostility where they have yeah you know
funnily enough people don't mention this
by actually Marcus is the oneness and
seems more sympathetic and he knows his
Epicurus said and I'm just curious but
to the Aristotelian tradition to because
brings up the offer asked us several
times but one of the best friends was an
Aristotelian yeah and fully Severus and
he actually his son-in-law his to
ToysRUs the TV tutor son was married to
one of Marcus's dogs both okay and they
they towards the end of his life with
Marcus travel to Athens for the first
time the Sun it was his son and more I
come to meet him so he had an
Aristotelian philosophers and then when
Marcus was there sound funded cheers for
criterion yeah Stuart and was it wallets
on it they just arrested feeling
announced until here for schools
yeah of philosophy and by then the plane
is Rebecca you know Plato's doctrines
reinterpreted as fact effectively the
middle and middle and Neoplatonism the
chemical assessment before you are
saying as far as we know we look quite a
surprising minor but Marcus's education
of twenty he had a platonic to talk it's
several story tutors master Tilly to
talk there's no major I'm gonna Iranian
the commune and household teaching him
yeah I'm attending any epicurean like
chose the only hand that we have is a
frontal and this is part was training in
rhetoric and frontal mentions that
Marcus were reading Lucretius oh and now
you know there were make sense and
Marcus's ratings he called some weight
after manicurist agreed which we don't
have another source yeah so they may be
whether it's paraphrasing or whether
he's so now we are pathetic to be in
ratings are Buster's to date he has
reports of a to be attributed Epicurious
but he also does this thing that the
other Stoics do that he seemed as he's
not he doesn't precise him in the way
that Seneca and I picked he destroyed
but he does do this of a failing system
system between all three of them that
they say Epicurious is of why is mine
incessant profound findings but they can
need to be mortified the Beth like so is
he cannot just say I agree with us yeah
like he kinda has to qualifier but has
to it has to be it has to be tweaked
yeah well this is before we run out
because I don't know how much battery
during it funny thank you very much for
this this great conversation I got some
excellent conversations over the last
couple days as well great conference
this year you know
yes everyone joy possible it for next
year not anymore
conversations over Joe talking to you
about my home be careful yeah yeah
thanks Tom
okay
you